youtube c'est squeeze on se retrouve
pour cette troisième vidéo détente sur
dead space 3 alors là tu viens de te
dire que je porte des lunettes
en fait absolument pas ce n'est pas la
mienne donc nous continuons notre île ce
faire les vidéos des tentes ouais
j'avoue le mec qui prépare sa blague
pendant quarante-deux minutes 1 alors
que l'hébergeur 5 seconde est que
personne ne rigole c'est à ces bateaux
alors on est sur des space 3 on vient
d'arriver sur une station on cherche la
botte de isaac cette partie là du golfe
il faut qu'on la trouve la vidéo du jour
à 15 minutes pour des raisons de timing
sinon j'aurais pas tant de faire le
rendu plus de l'aude et je sens ça pue
le monstre juste 16 ans en le monstre
aux loups salut c'est quoi c'était
distributeurs ahidjo il ya des pistes ou
burqa dans l'espace t'as vu c'est que
c'est quoi ça enfin yves un bruit et un
brin anachronique lequel une échelle
retard quand tu pourras c'est au vote
chez les unités d'énergie super ah voilà
parfait ok on va mettre ça la schl au
tout début du jeu 1 pour info nouvelles
missions facultatives fabriquer une arme
ah bah je veux bien je veux bien oui
tout ce titre c'est quoi ça moyennant
exotique au bon prix il faut que je
trouve un majeur or je crois que je
soufflais manon si on peut juste là
comment je fais oui oh my god je n'avais
jamais fabriquer d'armes bench bloc
moteur tesla bloc moteur tesla évangile
est bloqué oui oui je sais alors à me
voir demain pour jeter des circuits
ouais il avait évoqué à rome vous tapez
tuto vous devez trop bas de chaque arme
dispose d'un outil supérieur comme lise
et outils en bout suivant est par
exemple portable tient faire des progrès
sur merde bon c'est quoi
nick sa mère j'ai la flemme alors pour
continuer au monde et qui est celle on
prend peut vous voir et en donnant 3 2 3
ok c'est elle c'est parti ça sent
tellement pas bomber aux logiques moi
j'ai environ 10 kits de soins si je
meurs je dois être comme très très naze
oh non [ __ ] y avait des ânes on a je
suis désolé ouais quand je faisais des
vidéos à l'époque sur dead space 2 on
engueuler parce que je prenais jamais
les trucs là par terre alors là vous ne
gagnerez plus parce que je l'est pour
tous
hier l'équipe alors au monde ouais je me
souviens à l'époque c'est vrai que j'ai
fait des voeux sur des espèces de on
faisait couler pourquoi je vous prends
pas les crocos la barre car ma car voilà
up
oui j'ai bien fait bon malheureusement
vous allez vous détester parce que on
aura beau désordre [ __ ] y'a pas été
option jean redescendre rapidement d'une
échelle se téléporter c'est dans
l'espace mais qd je veux bien téléporter
lennon bon non plus on rigole mais
médaille et je crois que dernière
j'allais dire il y aura peut-être ces
combinaisons plus tard n'ya pas iron man
lac à un mec a voulu un peu faire comme
ils avaient des fusées au pied je crois
il a été lâché dans l'atmosphère enfin
pendant l'espace ans dans le ciel quoi
et ça a marché et lg vient de raimund
gènes et gl balayage de vous allez
vraiment mais détesté mais faut faire
quoi alors le mec au vote cette vidéo il
reste bloqué 22 minutes et 49 secondes
sur ça si tu fais un total de 4
milliards de centimes et ben vous avez
dû me détester quand je suis passé
devant [ __ ]
oh la vache ou lavage dictée des
amériques alba dental erkan présenta à
le bruit un [ __ ] j'aime pas du tout a
ébloui [ __ ] ça c'est quoi la [ __ ] ça
se ferme ça ça va s'ouvrir
ça sent tellement mauvais là là je suis
très anxieux obata je vais rentrer il va
descendre
je veux rentrer va descendre sd 110 100
m dos je t'attends mettre au pilori
prend une ignoble
oh la vache oh [ __ ] mais qu'ils soient
des mycoses la pole à 20 h il est
dégueulasse
l attaque à chabwa at on les écrase on
ramasse tout cas y mettant les moyens
bon ben si ça va chauffer
bien sûr visé les membres au quai ouest
hawaïenne et j'écoute hockey reste
éloigné des confédérations et c'est
complet c'est quoi c'est une pente pas
et s'ils coupent les membres et il faut
couper les membres d'accord tout à fait
j'ai l'habitude de campagne est membre
non je serai le métro que je fais quoi
avec ça je fais un parti à vente au sexe
y ait un bac es bon continue d'affecter
le risque dont la trop forte on est de
combiner ces pâles escroqué des bâtards
de maire de sarasota rasta à des gamins
de 17 ans sébastien tient non mais tu
appuies têtes mais tu marches encore
mais bien sûr mais bien sûr il y avait
qu un châssis dans ton collègue 12 merde
matin
je suis désolé mais c'est important de
leur casser le casser les membres pour
sa ces trucs genre après après l'effort
le réconfort
voilà continue moi je dois être l'homme
le plus lent au monde sur dead space
il en faut les battre ce plu ouvre toi
marché à bertoua
non on tourne on fait le tourniquet as
tu t'attends
oui
[ __ ] mais ce jeu en herbe et un accord
dégage dégage merde merde la dame a
dégagé ta gueule légal javier ferme ta
gueule sérieux vous savez ça peut
peut-être vous paraître con mais moi des
space est un jeu un des jeux qui me fait
vraiment le plus peur de tous les jeux
d'horreur bien plus que ça dort bien
plus que n'importe quel autre jeu dans
le sens où tu es tout seul dans l'espace
tumeur jamais à ça j'ai mal au bide
âgées une contraction du coeur la dia
collado n'y a pas un truc enfermé hockey
fermé au revoir ça va c'est le jeu
vraiment le jeu qui me fait flipper mais
vrai en mai mais c'est horrible veux
voir mes vidéos 2d space 2 je mettrais
bien dégagé c'est un [ __ ] de
confédération de merde [ __ ] c'est
vraiment le ca me fait plus peur que
zombie island länder et les jeunes à the
house machin mais franchement c est qu à
wade [ __ ] on peut les piques et j'ai
oublié sa raquette
bon allez on continue merde y'a quoi il
ya un bruit j'ai plus de munitions aux
hommes et si celui-ci bat cible de cyber
recharge bon tant pis aller on tourne on
tourne à l'onf et aux tourniquets on bat
les couilles je vous attends
au vrai feu mais qui rêve inachevé
vous n'êtes pas fait où j'arrive presque
à l'embranchement
à court de munitions attendez-vous
l'intérieur
la page les potes se font défoncer faut
qu'on fasse ça non j'aime pas ça ça
semble très très vivant lui je parie
qu'il est vivant on peut lui casser la
gueule
oui non t'es sérieux dans l'espace un
espèce de tota kullmann dégueulasse non
non non à giorgio ahwach au tout dégager
d'ici bordel emplois de merde au [ __ ]
mais aujourd'hui géré la gravité 3 kills
genre gravité un bâton mais de quoi tu
me parles
ou alors la gueule le coupé la gueule on
lui a coupé la gueule aux bâtards alors
toi mon gars je suis en mode binaire sur
ta gueule naga je veux jouer on va jouer
mais pas car je me cache
je reviens coco tu vois ma [ __ ] purement
lada soir ma [ __ ] et on adhère mon truc
on peut pas mettre des gros coups ne
peut pas ne pas récupérer s'il ya des
trucs qu'ils veulent c'est obligé non
c'est ça d'accord donc vous vous sert
vraiment à rien aidé par sylvain
éditions mare dans les mêmes patrons de
bar car les descends descends
moyen-orient continue au cours
one two week c'est bon parfait tandis
que j'ai dit il ya qu à chaque tour nico
on va prendre ça prend ça et je fais a
partout j'espère mabanda bon allez
encore six minutes de vidéo six unités
stress intense et un jour peu plus tard
ça voilà on parie je vais arriver
notamment si la faire sur moi et j'ai un
gros screamer des olas tours minutes ça
sent la gare ça sent la guerre mais
plein je sais que vous êtes là ouais
quand tu veux la source du vaisseau elle
s'est juste au dessus de moi je crois
que j'ai trouvé générateur principal
si j'arrive à l'alimenter vous pourrez
emprunter l'embranchement oui et bout
alors il ya un ascenseur qui monte à la
flèche
je vous retrouve encore donner
complètement ok ok d'accord fois que tu
fais ça à les tourniquets
un bordel ça à mettre en oies bâtard je
te vois je te vois je te vois là non je
t'ai vu plan gib à a
je viens de vous mettre en accéléré un
truc de quatre minutes alors qu'il
fallait juste maintenir la touche high
sing and the the big machine of the
world entre ici ou là je décolle pas et
je rigole pas ils veulent pas et ouais
ouais ouais tu veux faire la règle et
ouais bah ouais ça que je te vois pas
ouais de bâtard [ __ ] de merde tâche
passage durée bien quatre minutes bon
allez hop se dire je m'arrête à 23
hockey [ __ ] la vache mais quelle des
villes sérieux au monde jeune fille
train de merde je suis un autiste les
gens c-abs et limite je crois que je
pense je vais faire un code carrément je
n'aime pas le faire en accéléré bas pour
vous dire j'ai galéré cinq minutes comme
une grosse merde sur ça alors fallait
juste faire ça et rester appuyé sur v et
que c'est marqué dans mon dos quoi la
modiste c'est moi
la voir des mondes sont glissantes
oh oui chiottes dans mon cas car ce qui
manque
je suis qui manque sa passe à ce qui
manquait à l'autre bout yep je vais
aller au volant [ __ ] je peux pas en
volant c'est plus stylé t'as vu ça fait
genre un mec de l'espace combinaisons
jusqu'à
elle va démarrer genre
o'shea aussi parmesan
matin des caches de mende en mode au nom
des 300 points
mais les cheminots ne font pas des
derniers n'avaient pas de sens c'est bon
tiens tiens je te défonce moi je t'ai
fait chaud c'est bon là ils ont les
lions les guépards fait un peu aller là
non on devait rester fermé d'accord avec
cela et c'est cela qui est du coup la
fois que tu fais un truc ici je parie
voilà activée
mais j'aimais ça ta gueule olalala
métier john hocking toulouse général
ok on fait quoi maintenant on fait quoi
pour tourner savoie où je dois faire je
dois faire oui ou non c'est bon bah non
sens où je dois me paraît c'est de la
bouche verges paris ces notes du chemin
ici on utiliser la touche aux objectifs
l'eau douce la meilleure de dead space
ferez vous voyez vous appelez ascenseur
vous ne comprenez pas fait la touche
objectif elle vous dira tout ce que vous
devez faire son père bon allez pitié
battez les conneries tu as je crois pas
j'y passerais plates ou cinq minutes sur
ce générateur de merde
incroyable mais quel boulot ce quoi fait
juste rester en plus en gros dans l'eau
il ya marqué reste appuyé sur
bayroutistes les huitièmes on ne sait ce
qui lui reste à payer on sait que tu es
con à l'entrée d'un bois ça y est c'est
parti ou ambiance où j'aime pas ça là il
est beau quand même le mec t'es mon
portail qui n'a pas de ou de cnn
il fait chaud là je me tords j'avais
trois chocs auront pour cette vidéo jean
claque un sommet joker un peu de coca
c'est bon alors âgé dé retrouver aussi
sa chérie enchanté messieurs c'est le
mode à quoi je t'en prie
mais je vais me souvenir mais je m'en
bats les couilles je m'en bats les
couilles des moines bien monter leur
match de foot je prends soin d'eux
et ben voilà ça sonne bien pour une
vidéo et ben voilà
écoutez si vous voulez d'autres épisodes
sur dead space voulez d'autres vidéos
par don panoz puisoz par les blessures
des space ne sais pas me le dire
excusez moi là pour le code que j'ai pu
faire mais j'ai rarement guéréda mais
comme un autisme et comme comme une
grosse merde mais vraiment penche pas
combien de temps je voulais est allé
voir la vidéo détente numéro 4 dans une
heure et demie tout le monde puisse et à
bientôt